all focus turns to testing capacity but
how effective will testing me and how
practical are our testing plans plus
local officials get authoritarian and
protests start to roil the country I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn dot-com / Ben
that's expressive VPN dot-com / Ben well
I hope that you had a somewhat relaxing
weekend as we all continue to undergo
this incredibly painful and difficult
process obviously some people in the
United States are suffering gravely not
just in terms of health but tons and
tons of people have lost their jobs I
mean this is a crisis that is roiling
and in the middle of a roiling crisis
the last thing you need are people
taking political advantage of the
roiling crisis in order to enact their
agenda and this is why it's really
important to look to Europe and see how
they are reopening and look to the
various strategies on reopening it's why
it's really important to use critical
thinking when we talk about exactly what
sort of steps need to be taken for
reopening because there is a data based
idea that we can reopen if we hit
certain milestones and then there are
certain data free ideas like we can
never reopen at any point or we should
reopen immediately no holds barred no
masks no social distancing and and none
of this is useful so what we should
first do is look at the data and then
what we're gonna see is that American
politics it's amazing how fast people
retreat to their priors it's amazing how
fast people use crisis as an opportunity
to push their preferred political agenda
and how in response people immediately
say well you know what then I'm not
going to buy any of what you are saying
we've seen this with regard to climate
change for example so the left wasn't
content to simply just say listen
climate change is happening and it's
mostly human cause then it became this
is a global crisis it's a crisis of
unprecedented proportion and it also
means they're gonna have to completely
restructure the world economy and the
American economy and at that point a lot
of people began to think wait a second
wait a second I'm with you on the
science I'm okay with that
I'm even willing to go along with you on
maybe this is a serious problem over the
course of the next century that is
gradually building but I'm not willing
to go along with something that seems as
though it is a pretext for you to do all
the things you have already wanted to do
and that is what it is starting to feel
like in the United States as politicians
lock down beyond what is necessary as
they take more and more petty awful
Rotarians stances as you see people
attempting to shut down protest not on
the basis of public health alone by the
way if you are protesting if you're out
there protesting today or yesterday
recommendation okay I made this
recommendation last week if you're on a
protest to reopen the government I'm
actually fine with that I don't have
any problem with that that is a First
Amendment exercise not only that I sort
of agree with you that we need to be
taking more expert not sort of I largely
agree with you we need to be taking more
expedited steps to reopen America's
economy because I believe that the
American people are responsible I
believe the American people are capable
of wearing a mask when they are going to
be within six feet of others the
American people are capable of social
distancing then we are a free people who
are responsible and don't want to infect
our neighbors that being said if you're
gonna go out in protest why don't you do
that I wear a mask socially just since
takes a bullet away from the media that
wish to paint you as a bunch of kooks
there are some cooks out there
protesting but there are plenty of cooks
on the other side suggesting that we
must shelter in place until Kingdom Come
no matter what the economic consequences
are okay so we're gonna get into all of
this let's begin with what is happening
over in Europe so in Europe they are
beginning to slowly re-emerge from their
lockdown according to The Wall Street
Journal book stores almost nothing else
among again open again along desolate
canals of Venice restaurants and hotels
remain shut cafes ones packed with
tourists hit empty but for two days a
week customers can browse for books so
long as they wear a mask disinfect their
hands before shopping and stay more than
six feet apart to comply the city's
Marco Polo bookstore has asked customers
answer one at a time in the morning or
schedule a half hour appointment for the
afternoon for a look at how hard it is
to press play on Western economy still
battling coronavirus turn to Europe and
to Italy which is painstakingly freeing
its shops and small businesses and
stages easy and continent-wide lockdown
that is kept nearly half a billion
people at home nation by nation and in
some cases storefront by storefront
health authorities in the European Union
are selecting when and where a
commercial life can breathe again in
tiny gasps each new category of retail
allowed to function presents a real-time
experiment for what coming weeks could
look like as parts of the u.s. attempt
to follow most Italian regions have let
children's clothing stores open the
Czech Republic has green LED hardware
stores in central Vienna face masked
Austrians now line up around city blocks
to visit sewing shops in chocolatiers
this week Germany and Poland both said
they would loosen rules that have
suffocated retail the openings are
piecemeal and provisional there's no
Swift or substantial relief a lot of
people are still staying home but stores
are beginning to reopen it's gonna be
hard to get back online but countries
are taking sort of different tacks on
this sort of thing Germany is reopening
its stores according to Bloomberg News
Chancellor Angela Merkel's government is
now allowing smaller stores to reopen
after a shutdown the deprived German
retailers about 33 billion bucks
sails and push many shops to the brink
of bankruptcy Germany's among the first
nations in Europe taking cautious steps
toward normalcy as the pandemic
continues to shudder factories
restaurants and shops from Madrid to
Prague retail spaces of less than 800
square meters which is less than about
8,500 square feet will be reopening
along with car dealerships bike shops
bookstores Bar restaurants gyms larger
stores are going to remain closed the
government is urgently recommending that
everyone continue to wear face masks so
Germany is already beginning to reopen
and Sweden which never really shut they
are now saying that they've been
successful in their attempts to flatten
the curve now remember the the whole
situation with Sweden you know and and
people on the Left really love to hate
Sweden which is weird because the
government there is actually a central
life government but the the bizarre
notion that Sweden has blown this thing
because they had a spiking death rate
over the last couple of weeks and then
flattened out again this is like saying
that if you are overweight and then you
go to exercise and then you're vomiting
into a trash can the exercise is really
hard and then some points you say look
look at what that guy did to himself
he's vomiting in the trash can right the
point for Sweden is that you're supposed
to take the along you're supposed to
trade the short term hit a vomiting in
the trashcan for the long term gain of
getting back in shape if you just sit on
your couch all day you're actually not
doing yourself any favours because you
will be out of shape forever
okay so Sweden sort of took a different
tack which is we'll take the early hit
well make sure that our systems aren't
overrun and now Sweden is beginning to
say listen our strategy is working and
we'll see how you all are doing when you
re emerge and you embrace our strategy
anyway and then presumably have to
reinfect each other because that is
something that is going to happen people
completely misinterpreted what flatten
the curve net yeah I explained it 1,000
times on the show so today my fault but
flatten the curve simply meant that we
were going to spread out the rate of
infection over time such that we would
not overwhelm our medical system people
took it to mean that if we somehow
flatten the curve that you would never
get kovat that is not right okay you
probably will get cold but at some point
in the future barring some exigent
circumstance our only hope is that the
treatments are better and that a vaccine
is developed sooner rather than later
but flattening the curve never meant
that a huge percentage of the population
was going to avoid Co but it just meant
that there were going to be medical
resources at your disposal when you
actually did get Cove it in any case
we'll get to Sweden in just one second
first let us talk about how you can make
your car better right from your house
with the ever increasing number of makes
and models it is now impossible to stock
all the parts you need in a traditional
chain-store for him plus do you actually
really want to be going to the auto
parts store right now is that like a big
thing for you you really want to browse
around the auto parts store one reason
to repair and maintain your cars to save
money you can then use for other
important things like mortgage or food
why would you choose to spend 30 50 100
percent more for the exact same auto
parts at a chain store or new car
dealership like the Delphi FG 1456 fuel
pump assembly for the 2005 to 2010 Honda
Odyssey that'll run you like 354 bucks
at advance it'll only run you about 217
bucks at rockauto.com rockauto.com
it's a family business serving Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years head
on over to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they have
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's for your
classic or your daily driver get
everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
also remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle you can choose brand
specifications prices you prefer great
selection reliably low prices and or
shopping online so you're saving
yourself time and money and not having
to go to the store all masked and gloved
up go to rockauto.com right now see all
the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you go check them out right now
Rock Auto calm and use Shapiro's in
their how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sing so as I say
Sweden was much more accurate and how
they have been informing the public that
this thing is gonna go forward so they
never shut down all of their restaurants
or their gyms or their bars or anything
they basically just said to their
citizenry guys be responsible right if
you're old if you are if you are if you
a pre-existing condition
stay home don't go out and socialize but
otherwise you'll go out there where I'm
asked socially distance yeah don't
congregate in large in large throngs and
that's about it
and her signal is the architect behind
Sweden's relatively relaxed response to
kovat he told local media the latest
figures on infection rates and
fatalities indicate that the situation
is starting to stabilize
techno told Swedish news were so around
sort of a plateau Sweden has left its
schools gyms cafes bars and restaurants
open throughout the spread of the
pandemic the government has urged
citizens to act responsibly and follow
social distancing guidelines so there
are high levels of trust social trust in
places like Sweden and that makes it a
lot easier for people to rely on their
neighbors to obey the rules with that
said I believe that the American citizen
is generally a responsible human being
who is capable of going back to work and
wearing a mask and staying six feet away
from
people and not breathing all over each
other and frankly I am I'm bewildered
and somewhat terrified by the response
of local authorities who are doing the
dumbest crap I've ever seen on the local
level in order to prevent people from
supposedly reinfecting each other I mean
it totally is wild
it totally said we're gonna get to that
in just one second but I want to talk
about one of the things that people keep
talking about for reopening so they keep
talking about the necessity of testing
they keep saying that if we test with
ramp up test we need tests that are
ramped up really ramped up in order to
reopen society so we need to be
reasonable about what we expect when
people go back there will be an
increased number of people who are
infected when people go back there will
be an increased number of people who do
die and that is a thing that is going to
happen and there is no world none in
which people go back to work and don't
shelter in place and the rates don't go
up the rates will go up this is expected
this is part of the plan
unless there is some new treatment that
miraculously appears people will get
sick people will die the hope is that
when they go to the hospital a
ventilator will be available in ICU bed
will be available hopefully you'll have
some of the new drugs available right
that overtime as we hit September we get
back into the school year the treatments
the toolkit as dr. Scott Gottlieb former
FDA Commissioner put it to me on a
Sunday special the toolkit will have
improved such that the care for you will
be better by September the vaccine ain't
coming until next year
okay so acknowledge the baseline risk in
American society has gone up and kovat
has raised the baseline risk and
depending on your age in your
pre-existing condition it has raised
your baseline risk rather substantially
for sure and when people compare this to
the flu it's not like the fluid is much
more transmissible than the flu and it
is significantly more deadly than the
flu for every age range except for kids
who are under the age of maybe 15 years
old okay with all of that said we have
to know the limits of testing what is
the testing actually designed to do
because we've heard these sort of magic
words that get bandied about in the
media and then completely reinterpret it
so as I say flatten the curve was taken
by many Americans to mean that since we
flatten the curve you're gonna go back
to work and you're not gonna get it not
true okay testing does not mean you are
not going to get it okay what testing is
designed to do presumably testing and
contact tracing right these buzz words
that you hear that testing is designed
to identify people after they already
have it and then to lock down the the
levels of contexts or web of contacts
that they have until the
people to self-quarantine to kind of
kill out hot spots before they spread
exponentially that is the goal of the
testing now is that actually
accomplishable probably it's probably
accomplishable if you have a baseline
level of testing that is somewhat higher
than the level of testing we have now
doesn't mean that we are going to stamp
out the virus that the only way for us
to get back to work is to run tens of
millions of tests every day that's not
realistic it's just not realistic and
part of the reason it's not realistic
it's cuz tons of people presumably
particularly in metro hot spots have
already had this thing if so I've been
talking about the fact that well this is
a lot more deadly than the flu and a lot
more transmissible than the flu it is a
lot less deadly than the w-h-o rate
that's been put out there for the case
fatality rate the infection fatality
rate is the rate you actually need to
know the infection fatality rates when
I'm always talking about that is the
number of people who have actually
obtained this virus is much higher than
number of people who've been tested for
the virus the denominator is much much
higher and we keep seeing this which
means it's kind of difficult to lock
down it's kind of difficult to lock down
other than with just stay at home
measures now again if there's a big
hotspot a huge spike in one area then
maybe you can contact race if you do it
soon enough right that would be the goal
but that's the only goal of the testing
okay the goal of the testing is not to
prevent everyone in the population from
getting it or to prevent a low level of
baseline people infecting each other
from continuing that will continue that
is going to happen okay so let's be
realistic about what we can accomplish
and what we can't say I think people are
being utterly completely unrealistic
about this and I think some people are
doing that for political purposes one
because they want to imply the Trump
administration is capable of doing a
thing it can't do and the government is
capable of doing a thing it can't do and
they want to suggest that people need to
stay home indefinitely and this is where
I think that Americans are right to
begin getting suspicious there are some
people in positions of authority who are
obviously enjoying the shutdown a little
too much who are who are going out of
their way to shut down activities that
seriously have no relation to data or
reality and there are some people in
positions of authority who are seeing
this opportunity as an opportunity to
restructure all of American Society and
I'm not implying I'm not making an
accusation without evidence Bernie
Sanders wrote that directly in the New
York Times today so we'll get to that in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that every penny that you can
save right now is extremely
important including on that credit card
balance right now and get a low fixed
interest rate and free up more money in
your monthly budget which I can't
imagine a better time to do this you can
say goodbye to credit card bills take
even more control of your money light
stream their credit card consolidation
loans have rates from just five point
nine five percent APR with Auto pay
there are absolutely no fees people do
love light stream here's what one
customer had to say finding about a
light stream couldn't have come at a
better time I've been trying to
consolidate my debt for a few months now
I felt like I reached a dead end I was
listening to my podcast one morning and
heard their ad everything that was said
sounded too good to be true but at that
point I had nothing to lose so I checked
it out ultimately it was true easy quick
and convenient I wish I would have found
out about light stream sooner I 1000%
recommend this to everybody that's one
customer had to say apply today get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more like it's the responsible
thing to do in a time of economic
downturn which is certainly happening
it's very important you get in charge of
your debt get up on top of that debt the
only way to get this discount is to go
to light stream comm / Shapiro that's Li
ght stre am calm / appear elect stream
calm / Schapiro subject credit approval
rate includes 0.50% auto pay discount
terms and conditions apply offers are
subject to change without notice visit
light stream calm / appear o for more
information and go see what they can do
for you and help you consolidate that
credit card debt over at light stream
comm / shapiro so as i say this thing is
very widespread it's very widespread
right and in metro areas particularly
widespread we mentioned a study last
week very late last week on the radio
show it broke like after the podcast and
that that study showed that the baseline
level of infection in santa clara county
could be 50 to 85 times as high as the
number of actual tested cases we've seen
that in denmark for example the
percentage or the netherlands rather the
percentage of people in the netherlands
who had this antibody who had the
antibody this thing is like 3% of the
population which means that their
infection fatality rate is off by at
least an order of magnitude probably by
a factor of 20 and well now we are
seeing there's a study in massachusetts
in which they tested people literally
off the street the massachusetts general
study took samples from 200 residents on
the streets in Chelsea Massachusetts 64
of the participants tested positive so
like 1/3 of the people just on the
street tested positive for the antibody
which
means two things one it's a lot more
widespread than possible which means
testing for it's gonna be very difficult
but two it also means the thing is a lot
less deadly then you have led to pin led
to believe even if it is significantly
more deadly than the flu what all of
this is doing is it means that there is
a lot of uncertainty in the modeling it
means the people have less faith in the
scientists I'll tell you another thing
that is going to lead people to have
less faith in the scientists is all the
conflicting messages so let's talk about
testing because this is what you keep
hearing now right you keep hearing from
the politicians everything is about
testing
why isn't Trump testing where are all
the tests and it's true we need more
testing we do need more testing okay but
the level of testing that some people
are calling for is just utterly
unrealistic it's not realistic it's not
a thing that is going to happen I give
you an example today ABC News reports
that there is a report titled roadmap to
pandemic resilience released on Monday
morning a blue-ribbon panel of thought
leaders across the political spectrum
called Kovan 19 a profound threat to our
democracy comparable to the Great
Depression and World War two
Daniele Ellen lead author of the report
a professor at Harvard University's
Edmond J Safra Center on ethics told ABC
News it's a moment for a can to America
to really show up and put itself to work
we need a massively scale of testing
tracing and supported isolation system
that is the alternative
they say test producers will need to
deliver 5 million tests per day by early
June to safely open even parts of the
economy by late July to see it to fully
remobilize the economy the country will
need to see testing grow to 20 million a
day and we acknowledge that even this
number may not be high enough Paul Romer
the Nobel laureate economist who didn't
assist in the report but has a similar
approach according to ABC News says the
country may need more than 30 million
tests per day 30 million tests per day
guess what is not happening any of that
okay that is not a thing that is
happening so let's be realistic about
this and let's also be realistic about
what these tests do ok we have to be
realistic about the risks here okay
people are gonna go back to work and
there is gonna be additional risk so
let's let's be honest about it no one's
being honest with you the politicians
are not being honest and make it sound
like you're gonna be safe when you go
back to work it's not true commentators
are not being honest when they suggest
it with a massive regime of testing you
will be completely free of risk that's
not true there there are several
different types of tests that people
have talked about and all of them have
flaws
all of them first of all let's just put
this on the table people keep saying
we'll wait for the back team we'll wait
for that scene there's no guarantee that
even will be a vaccine
according to David Nabarro professor of
global health at Imperial College and
envoy for the w-h-o he says that there's
no guarantee a vaccine can even be
successfully developed so everybody is
sitting around going oh that'll be a
vaccine 12 to 18 months how do you know
so that may not happen it also turns out
that even if you test negative for Kovan
19 you may have it why because it turns
out that a lot of these tests are flawed
okay so you can test as much as you want
if the tests have a really high rate of
false positive or false negative not
super helpful
according to live science okay this is
just a few a couple of weeks ago
conventional diagnostic tests for the
novel coronavirus
may give a false negative results about
30% of the time 30% of the time so those
sorts of tests they're not gonna be good
enough okay they're just not and these
are the rt-pcr tests everybody is
talking about right these are the ones
that take a bit of RNA from your from a
viral swab from your nose from your
mouth and they replicate the RNA and
they match it up to the the genetic
sequencing of the virus and to see if
you have the virus in the first place
those things are significantly
inadequate in many cases if the tests
come back positive it's almost certain
you have the infection but if the tests
give a negative then it is not certain
that you're actually negative so giving
a false negative a lot of the time that
means that we would have to repeat test
you and how many times you have to
repeat tests before you determine that
somebody is actually clean also is
everybody to have an RNA test like on
the premises what's the delay between
the time you take the PCR testing the
time you receive the result cuz it might
be three days in which case you're still
going out because you feel okay right
you're not symptomatic one of the big
problems here is that you only take the
test when you're symptomatic unless you
are taking it preventatively in which
case you still have to wait for two to
three days in which case you're still
infecting everybody so depending on the
level of infection in society at large I
don't know what level of contact tracing
you think is going to be available for
330 million people but it's gonna have
to be pretty extraordinary there are
flaws in this approach okay then there's
the antibody test to the first of all
they're serious problems with antibody
tests right now according to the New
York Times today the United States has
seen the first roll out of blood test
for coronavirus antibodies but for all
their promise
the tests are already raising alarms
officials fear the effort may prove as
problematic as the earlier launch of
diagnostic tests that failed to monitor
which Americans and how many had been
infected or developed the disease or
develop the disease the virus causes the
FDA has allowed about 90 companies many
based in China to sell tests that have
not gotten government vetting saying the
pandemic warrants and urgent response
the agency has since warned that some of
these businesses are making false claims
about their products and so many of the
tests going around don't have any level
of validity at all they have like 20%
validity so there are flaws in the
antibody test and again the antibodies
only develop after a week so you could
have it walk around for a week be
infecting everybody so here's what tests
are good for they're good for if you and
a bunch of your friends start to get
sick then we can contact trace you after
two or three days of you being sick and
try and back trace you for like nine
days but it'd have to be you and a bunch
of your friends to justify the contact
tracing that would take place in that
hot spot right so that that means that a
low level of infection is probably going
to maintain throughout society now one
of the things that is happening is
because people are focusing so much on
the testing and the things that we have
to get done before we can supposedly go
back to work one of the things that is
happening is that people are sort of
waiting for for somebody to give them
the all-clear and I don't know that the
all-clear is going to be all clear
because again I think politicians are
lying to you I think right now the
testing has turned into a bit of a
political football
so we'll get to the political football
of the testing in just one second first
let's talk about how right now like more
than any time in human history you need
to have good reading resources for your
kids at home this is why I love literati
this is an amazing service literati is
the subscription book club that makes it
easy to find unique thought-provoking
books for your kids they deliver great
stories straight to your doorstep
literati knows home deliveries are
critical for meeting your need for
uplifting educational tools in the
coming weeks I mean if your kid's school
has been cancelled like my kids schools
have been canceled we need ways to
entertain and educate our children and
literati is an amazing way to do this
reading books together helps create a
time of adventure and bonding for your
family and has real educational benefits
kids who read books have better
vocabularies and longer attention spans
each literary box contains five
beautiful books based on a theme
contains exclusive original art and a
personalized note to your kid which is
really fun my kids get a kick out of it
literati actively curates stories that
sparked area
and promote independent thinking saving
you hours of searching the online
bookstores scrolling through lists of
books that are useless also literati
beats the Amazon list price so you're
saving money as one I love Amazon but
literati is better for this only keep
your favourites and send back the rest
for free which means you're only paying
for the books your kids love you can
reuse that literati box to donate
outgrown books literati will match every
one you send I mean I have three kids
under the age of seven literati is
indispensable for a limited time ago two
literati calm slash up hero for 25% off
your first two orders this is their best
offer available anywhere to get it you
have to go to literati calm slash up
hero for 25 percent off your first two
orders literati calm splashy apparel
literati calm slash up hero okay so to
get back on the testing there's been a
lot of talk about what people need to do
in order to have a testing level
sufficient that you can go back to work
I talked last week about the fact that
temperature tests at the front door
that's kind of like a third that's like
a third priority because you're only
gonna get a temperature week after you
have this thing antibody tests are only
gonna give you the antibodies a week
after you have this thing you're
probably only gonna take a PCR test
depending on how many tests are
available to three days after you have
this thing and then the results may not
come back for two or three days and all
of these tests have fairly significant
high false negative rates so in other
words we can't wait for this thing to be
perfect it's what I'm telling you and
all of the focus on this thing has to be
perfect before anybody goes back to work
is not it's not accurate it's just a way
politically for people to blame the
federal government for failures here and
you see this with Nancy Pelosi so Nancy
Pelosi over the weekend she says
President Trump gets an F on testing and
F on testing it has to be testing it has
to be tracing contact tracing it has to
be treatment and it has to be
quarantined it's part of something
bigger as well to be done properly but
we're way late on it and that is the
failure the president gets an F a
failure on the testing but the fact is
dr. fellas right if it is done properly
it hasn't been and that I think really
puts it in the if it's done is it
admission that it hasn't been done I
would love to ask her what she thinks is
proper and how she preserved how she
presumes to roll those out and fund it
and what American life looks like nobody
ever asked the follow-up question which
is okay you keep saying things like
testing and contact tracing what do you
mean how many people you gonna hire you
know people with the DMV doing contact
tracing
millions of people doing contact tracing
how many people are you going to have
actually doing the test how many tests
you proposed to roll out is it 20
million a day seriously 20 million a day
is that your plan
because that ain't happening it's not
happening it's not happening in May it's
not happening in June it's not happening
in July it's never happening there will
not be 20 million tests a day in the
United States let's be realistic about
this the country of 330 million people
and by the way I'm still confused as to
why 20 million tests today would be
sufficient there are 330 million people
in the population right by the way every
day that goes by millions people are
losing their livelihoods their jobs
populating the food banks right Mike
Pence is saying listen we've made as
much testing available as we're going to
be making available to the states
there's enough testing for people to
start to think about getting back to
work here's the vice president we
believe the testing that we have today
Chris across the country once we
activate all of the labs that can do
coronavirus testing is sufficient for
any state in America to move into phase
one we're doing about a hundred and
fifty thousand tests a day and you
remember a month ago we had done 80
thousand tests total now we've cleared
four million overall okay 150,000 tests
a day is good it's gonna need to be a
little bit better Scott Scott Gottlieb
told me on the Sunday special three
hundred thousand tests today would
probably be sufficient to at least do
the hot spot tracing and that's pretty
much all you can do again have realistic
expectations about what the testing is
going to do now Larry Hogan the governor
of Maryland who's also been a guest on
the radio show he says it's not true we
don't have the testing so you know when
the federal government says that we are
ready to go back that's not that's not
accurate the administration I think is
trying to ramp up testing try they are
doing some things with respect to
private labs but to try to push this off
to say that the governors have plenty of
testing and they should just get to work
on testing somehow we aren't doing our
job is just absolutely false every
governor in America has been pushing and
fighting and clawing to get more tests
not only from the federal government but
from every private lab in America and
from all across the world and we
continue to do so all of that is fine
and all that is good like maybe the feds
can do more maybe the states can do more
but all I'm saying is that testing is
not the cure-all everybody's acting
first the cure-all was flatten on the
curve so we flattened the curve wasn't
the care all then the creamy the
cure-all is going to be lots and lots of
tests except and it's not going to be a
cure-all it turns out
that unless you're the real cure-all is
people making responsible decisions
truthfully the real cure-all is going to
aside from any vaccine which again is
perspective the real cure-all is going
to be if you are at risk if you're
elderly if you have a pre-existing
condition seeing if there is a way for
you to distance yourself from other
human beings and if you are not and
making sure that you are responsible in
the way that you deal with other human
beings responsibility you know all of
this has led to a belief by most
Americans that they can't lift the stay
at home orders but that is because even
the conditions laid out by the White
House are now being politicized to the
extent that what was a fairly broad and
easy criteria to meet meaning that
you've had 14 days on a consistent level
of down slope in terms of diagnosed
cases or diagnosed cases as a percentage
of cases taken and they can start to
reopen the economy even that's being
politicized now they said testing has to
be sufficient and so of course everybody
on both sides of the political aisle has
honed in Don okay what level of testing
is sufficient and nobody has a great
answer for this naturally Americans are
worried about going back to work because
they've been told that if they go back
to work they're going to die and this is
why I've been very upset about frankly
how the media have covered this thing
because if you are young and healthy the
chance is that you're going to die if
you go back to work are extraordinarily
well like really really really low the
full number of Americans who have died
under the age of 45
with or without pre-existing conditions
in the United States from this thing
exceedingly low so what we should be
everybody's gonna end up in Sweden
everybody's gonna up doing the Swedish
thing it the only question is how long
you wait to do the Swedish thing right
now this is turning into a partisan
issue as well if you see how it breaks
down
and people are wondering like why is
this partisan it shouldn't be partisan
right I mean like we all have the same
risk to life as general rule right some
of us have pre-existing conditions some
of us are older some of us are more
vulnerable but overall everybody's at
risk the virus can take anybody out so
why is there a partisan breakdown the
reason there's a partisan breakdown is
because there's a backlash that is
currently brewing and the backlash is
brewing to a to a hardcore political
left that feels as though they are
entitled to politicize this thing and
turn it into a referendum on the entire
American system and seem to frankly be
enjoying their power a little bit too
much I've been saying for weeks that
Tarkin the tighter you you the tighter
you grip the more galaxies will slip
through your fingers and that's exactly
what's happening and wait until I show
you what's been
happening in some of these states
Americans are not going to stand for it
they are not Americans are not going to
be okay with the idea that they can't go
outside to a park I mean this is
insanity
and it's especially insanity when you
tell us we can't go out to a park maybe
you'll get a check in the mail maybe
we'll see about it we're kind of holding
up this this small business fun so maybe
I'll get a check in the mail maybe you
won't you're gonna stay home we'll make
sure the states get bailed out so all
the debt that we've been taking on for
years will make sure that the states get
a bill is what Democrats are focused on
today and also you can't send your kids
to school and also maybe at some point
there will be testing sufficient that
you can go outside but we're gonna have
to fundamentally restructure American
Society in the meantime you think that
might make people suspicious you think
it might make people suspicious when you
see that Facebook has been told by local
governments to remove notices of
protests doesn't I think a lot of
protesters are doing dumb things like
don't go to don't go to a rally and call
your governor or Nazi don't go to a
rally and and yell it and dr. Falchi
don't go to a rally and and take off a
mask and spit it be like just don't do
dumb things but the notion that
governments should be pressured to
reopen because we are a responsible
people capable of taking risks I'm with
you there I am and the media is attempt
to paint everybody who's in favor of
reopening as a threat to human life is
frankly disgusting I mean truly gross
we'll get to this in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
you're at home right now you may as well
emerge from that cocoon as a butterfly
well right now if you are self-conscious
about your photos you just want have a
nicer smile I recommend you check out
candid beyond delivering clear aligners
directly to your door candid treatment
includes remote monitoring by your
orthodontists throughout treatment that
means you get the same treatment
oversight you'd get by seeing an
orthodontist in person without having to
see an actual person all for a fraction
of the cost unlike braces candid clear
aligners they're comfortable removable
totally invisible so you can transform
your smile without anyone noticing a
thing plus your treatment is prescribed
and monitored remotely by licensed
orthodontists unlike other companies and
it only works with orthodontists never
general dentists which means your
treatment will be designed by an expert
in tooth with other remote clear aligner
options you may not hear from a doctor
at all as you go through treatment with
candid not only will your treatment be
designed by an experienced orthodontist
it also includes remote monitoring by
that same orthodontist throughout so
this is a great deal makes you teeth
straight you look beautiful when you get
out there so are you ready to take the
first
toward straighter teeth for a limited
time you can get started with 75 bucks
off using a code Shapiro at Candide
cocom slash Shapiro
that's Kenan Co comm / Ypres it's really
easy I've done it myself
use code Shapiro for 75 bucks off candid
code calm slash Shapiro use code Shapiro
right now okay we're gonna get into the
petty tyranny of local officials and the
burgeoning sense that some politicians
are using this crisis as an opportunity
Americans are not gonna stand for that
bullcrap and they shouldn't stand for
that bullcrap we'll get to that in just
one second first this Wednesday April
22nd we're going to be having a socially
distanced backstage live so Andrew
Klavan is going to be at home I think
we're all gonna be doing it from home
but that's because we are being
responsible at this thing we are
responsible citizen sir it's daily wear
so we'll be hanging out with you in Daly
we're backstage plus our all-access live
continues each and every day if you are
a member of any level right now then you
are able to access our all-access live
and ask me questions asked Clavin
questions and Noel's questions and and
Jeremy Boren questions you can go check
that out right now I believe I'm going
tonight for the all-access live so my
rule is I wear a t-shirt what t-shirt
will I wear I know what a pitch what a
picture anyway go over to daily wear
come subscribe right now any level of
member gets access to that we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so the dichotomy that's been set up
because of the testing regimen and the
control and the contact tracing I want
all this stuff in place to I have the
same interest you do I don't want hot
spots I live in LA you think I want a
hot spot out here I'm not interested in
that
I have friends I've I have a sister in
New Jersey like which is a hot spot
right now I would love all these things
in place but if you think that we can
wait until everything until we have 20
million tests a day as these non
epidemiologists by the way are
recommending you're out of your mind but
what the media are now setting up is a
political binary wherein if you suggest
that we need to consciously cautiously
responsibly get people back to work
particularly in the least vulnerable
populations then you are a bad person
who's risking human life and I'm sorry
that's a bunch of crap Thomas Friedman
has a column today along these lines
says Trump is asking us to play Russian
roulette with our lives this is what
Trump was saying with his liberate
Virginia liberate Minnesota liberate
Michigan tweets right Trump tweeted all
this last week without any sort of
clarifying message said everybody just
go back to work from now on each of us
individually in our society collectively
is going to play Russian Roulettes as
Thomas Friedman we're gonna bet we can
spin through our daily lives work
shopping school travel without
coronavirus landing on us and if it does
we'll also bet it won't kill us more
specifically as a society we'll be
betting that as large numbers of people
stop sheltering in place the number of
people who will get infected with Koba
19 and require hospitalization will be
less than the number of hospital beds
ICU respirators doctors nurses and
protective gear needed to take care of
them because it's clear that millions of
Americans are going to stop sheltering
in place before we have proper testing
tracking and tracing system let up until
we have a vaccine that kind of system is
the only path to dramatically lowering
the risk of infection while partially
opening society as Germany has
demonstrated as individuals every person
will be playing Russian roulette every
minute of the day what will be so cool
about this American version of Russian
Roulette is how unfair it will be and
then he turns it into class warfare if
you're more poor then you're going to be
forced to make choices listen I think
that everybody is gonna be forced to
make choices in their daily life and
those risks are going to change
obviously based on where you live and
what sort of job you have but what is
the alternative like seriously is Thomas
Friedman suggesting and we're all
supposed to shelter in place till July
Thomas Friedman has his cush salary paid
by the New York Times well he gets to
sit in his apartment and write garbage
for the pages of the op-ed
that like it's pretty easy for him to
say this stuff I know people who are
losing small businesses now 22 million
people have lost their job in the last
three weeks
hey this is so-so Thomas Friedman
suggests it may work out for some places
in people it may not I don't know every
choice in dealing with this virus is
fraught with huge trade-offs I just know
three things first this is the bet Trump
is urging you to make in his liber8
tweets when he should be ordering the
National Guard and mobilizing American
industry to get testing everywhere a
second this belt will fall verily on
very unfairly and unevenly in our
society when so little testing and
tracing is in place by the way when
matter even if the testing and tracing
were available every death is going to
be blamed on Trump because the media
have an interest in blaming the deaths
on Trump I'm amazed at how the media
have been able so Democrats been able to
turn this into a referendum on Trump
well let's be real about this America
has responded in the middle of the pack
in Europe better than a lot of countries
in Europe okay and I'm not seeing the
sort of criticism levering levied
against the Italian government or the
Spanish government by many of the same
people it's all about Trump Trump all
the time and then Friedman says your
president is telling you you're on your
own to make these decisions if your
strategy works you can be sure he will
take by the way I have a question is
that what it means to be a free human
being they are on your own to make
certain decisions like isn't that one of
the things that that makes you a member
of the free society
I'm not saying that there aren't
government mandates that are necessary
shutdown orders that are sometimes be
necessary or that there are quarantines
they're not going to be necessary but
once we have established whatever is the
lowest risk we can establish practically
speaking in forthright timely manner yes
that's called living a free life it's
called understanding what the risks are
and being respond again being
responsible I'm not saying everybody
rush out and go to the beaches and start
making out I'm saying be responsible and
by the way like the media's coverage of
this stuff is irresponsible I saw a
picture of a Florida beach yesterday and
people going nuts over it oh my God look
at all the people on the Florida beach
the picture was a lot of people on the
beach all of them six feet away from
each other that's not dangerous folks
okay it isn't the number of people who
have actually obtained this in China
from being an outdoor spaces according
to one study was to and it's to people
who are standing right next to each
other and talking for like 20 minutes
okay that's we're seeing we're seeing
the sort of petty tyranny being being
crammed down on Americans at an
increasingly rapid rate so bill de
blasio is a perfect example of this he
idiot mayor of New York who by the way I
loved that he was ripping the federal
government and Trump while he was
telling people they should go out and
celebrate their lives in New York didn't
order a shutdown order in New York until
nearly the end of March and then says we
shouldn't look backward now Bill
DeBlasio is is telling you to inform on
your parents Stasi style if they are if
they are not socially distancing I don't
know what this means like you see two
people and they walk three feet apart
you're supposed to send a picture to
build a Blasio if you're talking about
people who are violating shutdown orders
how bill de blasio hiking in the park
with his wife which is apparently I
think he's been doing here's the mayor
of New York going full Stalin we still
know there's some people need to get the
message and that means sometimes making
sure the enforcement is there to educate
people and make clear we got to have
social distancing so now it is easier
than ever when you see a crowd when you
see a line that's not distance when you
see a supermarket that's too crowded
anything you can report it right away so
we can get help there to fix the problem
and now it's as simple as taking a photo
all you gotta do is take the photo and
put the location with it and bang send a
photo like this and we will make sure
that enforcement comes right away it's
he hi like are these people hi what
really how's that going to be effective
how's it gonna be effective you think
the stores have an interest in people
not socially distancing and if you see
somebody who's talking with somebody and
you call the cops on them you think that
the cop and like how many cops are there
in New York City half the forces out
because they've got coronavirus what the
hell is he talking about okay that
wasn't even the worst example of local
idiocy over the weekend there was a
bunch of it in LA so I was driving
around as I'm want to do with my
children because as a normal human being
I like to put my children in the car and
show them there is a broader world than
just the roof of our house so we get in
our car and we drive over to a city
that's not insane Burbank ok Burbank is
a city that does not have the LA city
government this is why the valley should
have seceded from the city long ago in
LA
ok Burbank has a it signs up at their
parks and said play responsibly be
responsible so you drove past in Burbank
parks there were people outside there
were people playing catch with their
kids guess what they all were doing
socially distancing most of them were
wearing masks most people are
responsible enough to handle freedom by
the way
if you don't believe people are
responsible to generally responsible
enough to generally in in situations
where freedom can be exercised exercise
freedom I don't know why you're living
in a free country I really know
okay so Burbank is doing it right la is
doing it totally wrong they've shut down
every Park in the city every single one
to the extent that we drove along well
Highland Drive yesterday the city of La
had deployed workers to go to the turn
offs on Mulholland Drive which are no
bigger than this studio ok the turn offs
on Mulholland Drive are like seven
square feet
they had deployed people there to put
yellow ribbon across the turnouts and so
they're going to be masses of people
gathering at these little turnouts on
Mulholland Drive to spit on each other
and give each other covered okay that
wasn't even the dumbest thing Venice
Beach Venice Beach they brought
bulldozers to pile sands into these
skate parks of Venice Beach now as you
can see this tape is taken during the
day right this is this is early morning
pretty obviously and they're piling
giant piles of sand into the middle of
the skate park which presumably were
then gonna have it's great it's a great
government employment program we dig
holes and then we pay people to create
the holes and then we are gonna pay
these people to clean up the holes in
five minutes so they're piling sand
there so that people will not be
congregating and gathering there when of
course people is there like great
evidence that there are lots of PR you
seeing tons of people are like you can
see in the in the video there's no one
there it's like 6:00 in the morning by
the way when people say well that's 6:00
in the morning there aren't that many
people on Venice Beach at 6:00 in the
morning if you ever go to Venice Beach
there are lots of people who are walking
the walkway and virtually every time
during a non pandemic time they filled
in a frickin skatepark with dirt
because they don't trust you that much
this is this is wild ok Gretchen Whitmer
and in Michigan is doing some of the
same sort of stuff she has prevented you
from going to your second house if you
have a house like a lake house that's
away from the city she won't let you go
from one house to the other
she's preventing you from buying
gardening supplies Gretchen Whitmer and
then Gretchen Whitmer suggested no I'm
standing by these state lockdown
policies they're good she's got a pretty
easy she's apparently got a t-shirt
maker who helps make t-shirts for her so
that when she appears on Stephen Colbert
she can have her customized t-shirt just
for Stephen Colbert but she's willing to
shut down everybody's life over in
Michigan here she wasn't Meet the Press
defending her policies
you have any regrets on any of the
restrictions that you have put into
place I don't and here's why
you know Michigan right now has the
third highest number of death from covet
19 and yet we're the 10th largest state
we are have a disproportionate problem
in the state of Michigan and so we could
take the same kinds of actions other
states have but it doesn't rise to the
challenge we're confronted and that's
precisely why we have to take a more
aggressive stand it's working we are
seeing the curve start to platen by the
way there is not tremendous evidence by
the whether the states that have locked
down are doing significantly better than
states that have not locked down because
there are different states in the
country there are people who are
tweeting out statistics on the rise in
Cova diagnosis and states like Texas in
Florida Texas in Florida basically
flatten the curve and neither one of
them did a statewide lock down the way
the Gretchen Whitmer is doing a
statewide lock down certainly they're
not preventing people from being in
their gardens and gardening and buying
seeds or buying car seats the way the
Gretchen Whitmer was and then Gretchen
Wimmer is she's just awful Gretchen
Whitmer told Rachel Maddow there's a
protest at Michigan's Capitol she said
that that is the kind of irresponsible
action that puts us in the situation
where we might have to actually think
about extending stay at home orders
which is supposedly what they are
protesting so in other words if you
protest little kids we are going to
force you to stay in your houses even
longer do you get the feeling that some
of these local officials are enjoying
this power a little bit too much the
petty authoritarians like to be petty
authoritarianism because if you want
people to trust the experts you stay
home you have to have the feeling they
don't have an ulterior motive which is
to run for vice presidents in the case
of Gretchen Whitmer and become a
political hot button you also have to
have the belief that the government is
not maximizing its own presence in
American lives because this is what
government does and there are people who
want to make it permanent
and unfortunately that suspicion is
being justified each and every day by
folks on the radical left as well now
the new narrative is that government is
everywhere now and we're all used to a
Dan Balz has a piece over at the
Washington Post
he says Americans are experiencing the
biggest expansion of government
authority in generations as elected
leaders take unprecedented action to
fight the deadly coronavirus pandemic
the role of government has changed
overnight
despite a broad consensus behind this
emergency surge in government spending
in power a huge debate over what
government does and should do lies
head that battle will be waged on terms
that could be far different from those
that existed before the pandemic terms
that have held sway since President
Reagan arrived in Washington for decades
ago determined to put advocates of a
vigorous government on the defensive for
the first time since the New Deal
the pandemic says Dan Balz has exposed
crippling weaknesses in the federal
government troubling vulnerabilities in
society there'll be more difficult to
ignore when the crisis begins to ease
for the first time many Americans are
looking to government for their very
economic survival in time that could
make them look at government differently
well I mean can you hear Dan Balz
praying for this to happen can you
because this is where people start to
lose it and where people start to lose
it and I've said this before I've been
willing to go along with the measures
that I think are scientifically
justified I am NOT going to go along
with the lockdown mentality that
suggests that we need to fundamentally
restructure American society because a
virus hit us that this is now an excuse
to fundamentally remake everything and
Dan Balz is calling for that right he
says the effects of hollowed-out federal
agencies persistent under investment in
Public Health enormous gaps in coverage
disparities in care have been on daily
display as the corona virus spread
rapidly this winter in spring so to have
the effects of an economy whose benefits
are distributed unequally there it is
leaving the richest Americans secure
while millions upon millions of middle
and lower class families struggle even
in the best of times so this is now an
excuse for redistribution ISM it's an
excuse for complete remaking of American
society and then you wonder why people
are protesting and the media are
condemning these people as idiots and
fools they're condemning these people as
racists and bigots the Huffington Post
is comparing them to the Charlottesville
protestors okay if there are protestors
out there who are white supremacist I
can guarantee you they are not nearly
the mature that this is not a white
supremacist March okay if you see a
white supremacist at one of these
marches
first of all persons a scumbag second of
all from what I've seen those people are
outliers okay I've not been seeing huge
swaths of white supremacist on these
lawns I'm seeing a lot of citizens who
own small businesses and want to go back
to work and to compare them to the
Charlottesville protesters as The
Huffington Post it today is truly is
truly a radical move and then you wonder
why people are like okay so I feel like
you are using this here I feel like
you're using this politically it's quite
gross now in a second I'm going to talk
about just how gross this is when you
get two things I hate because there's
play
to hate today quick a thing I like so I
mentioned earlier reading with your kids
so one book that I've been reading with
my kids and it's kind of astonishing my
three-year-old even likes it he's a
Little House on the Prairie by Laura
Ingalls Wilder basically if you want to
learn how to build a house out of logs
this is the way to do it like it has
detailed descriptions are essentially
how you build a house in the middle of
nowhere Little House on the Prairie it's
enjoyable it has now been labeled wrong
think by the politically correct because
there are descriptions of Native
Americans that are not entirely
flattering because it was written from
the perspective of a settler in Indian
Territory you can explain all that stuff
to your kids there's a way to explain to
your kids that there was a legitimate
conflict over this land I did this
actually with my kids as we were talking
about this the book itself is really
enjoyable it's great and they have some
Illustrated versions if the kids like
pictures that are really good to go
check out Little House on the Prairie
plus the series you'll be my kids start
watching the series I never watched it
growing up the series is pretty great as
well
and my kids are really really into it
too go check out Little House on the
Prairie good clean fun other things that
I like so Bill Maher there are two clips
of Bill Maher that were going on they
were going around over the weekend one
clip of Bill Maher was a clip of him
having a conversation with
representative Dan Crenshaw my friend
Dan Crenshaw and he is basically
questioning Trump's coronavirus response
suggesting that it was really late and
really bad and Dan really sort of
reeducate him on the timeline and points
out that you can certainly criticize
President Trump but let's be real about
this Bill DeBlasio was walking around in
early March saying everything was fine
Eric Garcetti in LA was holding the LA
Marathon and saying whose right to do so
on March 8th like the foreign countries
many of them didn't lock down until
mid-march so that clip has gone viral
for good reasons and does an excellent
job of explaining all of this to to Bill
Maher well I think when it comes to his
coverage of the Trump administration has
been taken in by the the media narrative
which is that everything Trump does is
wrong and everything his opponents to
his right now Trump can do things wrong
and his opponents can also suck many of
these things can be true it can be true
that everyone is incompetent government
is awful at everything this is one of
the most bizarre things about the call
for radical revision of the nature of
American government and its relationship
with the citizens one of the things that
so bizarre and weird about it frankly is
that the government has really blown
this I mean in massive massive ways and
your response is that in non crisis
times that the government should run
everything anyway so Bill Maher and then
Dan Crenshaw that's a clip worth watch
but when I want to focus on his bill
Mahr actually doing something right so
bill maher went after the media over the
weekend and he said that the the members
of the media are really enjoying this
sort of panic porn and he is correct
about this he's correct about this they
are enjoying the panic porn because many
of them are sitting comfortably with
their jobs many of them don't have to
get on the subway and go to work many of
them don't have to go to a job
none of them are small business owners
here's bill maher pointing out you know
guys we are gonna have to reopen at some
point and your panic horn is not helping
you know the problem with non-stop gloom
and doom as it gives Trump the chance to
play the optimist and optimists tend to
win American elections FDR said the only
thing we have to fear is fear itself you
know as foolish as he is I can see Trump
riding that into a second term and then
there will be no hope left for you to
shame so look if this insanity happens
again news sources have to rein it in
everyone knows Corona is no walk in the
park
because you literally can't walk in the
park but at some point the daily
drumbeat of depression and terror veers
into panic porn he is exactly right
about this and good for Bill Maher for
pointing to he got all sorts of flack
for this it's not panic porn we're being
responsible in our coverage the media
have been utterly irresponsible in their
coverage from day one on all this this
is not to alleviate any member of
government for irresponsibility
Republican or Democrat but the media's
coverage of this stuff has been surely
bad really really bad I mean I don't
consider myself world's best interviewer
I've asked better questions on public
policy to every major official involved
in the decision-making process than
nearly anybody who's that these press
conferences at the White House because
they are so busy focusing on mr.
president you tweeted this today and
wasn't that very bad of you how about
your actions back in February bad mr.
president all the focus has been on
Trump because Trump is this black hole
of attention that sucks in the media and
Trump enjoys it because he likes the
back-and-forth with the media he did a
press conference yesterday where he was
just going back and forth with NPR and
CNN in The New York Times and the
American people are sitting there going
okay so I'm not really fond of how Trump
is is you know treating the men
you have a do I care am i spending my
days worrying about that but the members
of the media are spending their days
doing two things talking up how
dangerous this thing is and not leading
with the facts not leading with the
stats not leading with the responsible
coverage of what Americans can and
cannot do I mean if you read the media
and all you read with the headlines you
would think that if you go outside you
will get this thing and that if you get
this thing you will buy right that both
of those things are true if you go
outside if you touch a thing
anything doesn't matter what it is you
will die if you walk outside your house
without a mask
you're gonna die it doesn't matter if
there's person for a hundred miles
around you will die right that that is
the nature of the media coverage that
has been pushed to this point and Mars
right that is gonna benefit Trump
because if it turns out that all of the
insane overwrought coverage by the media
if that overall coverage results in
Trump saying listen it's gonna be bad
we're gonna make it through this thing
and then we make it through this thing
they're gonna be hard-pressed to explain
why okay time for a thing that I hate
all righty so you can see the narrative
starting to change the narrative is
starting to change for at the left and
the narrative is going to be that
President Trump didn't just blow this
thing president Trump blew this thing
because he is a racist right that that
is the way that this is going to move
and the reason that it's going to move
this way for the left is because this is
always wait moves for Republicans
so during Hurricane Katrina the initial
rip on President Trump on President Bush
was the president Bush handling
competently the federal government FEMA
should have been there that heck of a
job brownie it was not a heck of a job
then it quickly moved into the reason
the reason that george w bush mishandled
katrina is cuz it affected black people
and because george w bush didn't like
black people so i predicted a couple of
weeks ago this was the direction the
narrative was gonna move is that the
trump administration blue the response
and the reason they blue the responses
they didn't care enough about minorities
so the new york times has been running
it with headlines nearly every day that
are almost exactly the parodic headline
once suggested about the new york times
there's a very famous joke back in the
60s and 70s the new york times is gonna
run a headline saying asteroid to
destroy earth tomorrow women and
minorities hardest hit and that's
basically the coverage they're running
now the coverage they are running is
coronavirus to destroy all of america
and world society women and minorities
hardest hit although in this case would
be men in minorities because women are
actually
less hard-hit than men are okay well
here is the problem with that corona
virus is a threat to everyone right now
and if you are looking at sort of the
cross-cutting currents in terms of
threats race is not the best corollary
race does not correlate the best race is
not correlate the best okay what
correlates the best is pre-existing
health conditions in age those are the
things that correlate because it's not
like the virus is killing black people
versus white people the virus is killing
people who have diabetes versus people
who don't have diabetes the virus does
not prey on people as a matter of race
it preys on people as a matter of
pre-existing health condition and as a
matter of age scientifically speaking
your melanin level has nothing to do
whatsoever with how the virus affect you
now there may be a higher correlation of
pre-existing health conditions and age
and poverty which leads to pre-existing
health conditions with particular races
but that does not mean that the virus is
racist and it also does not mean that if
you are black and if you are overweight
and if you have diabetes that the reason
that you are dying of coronavirus is
because American society is racist there
are a lot of decisions the whole chain
of decisions that go into how people eat
how people live maybe it's partially the
legacy of racism
maybe it's partially the legacy of what
you do on a daily basis but what we are
starting to see is a shift in the media
and in the coverage toward America is
racist and that's why more black people
are dying right which is the same as
America is racist and that's why more
black people are poor okay not America
was racist and therefore there are
lingering effects of racism in American
society America continues to be racist
and that's why we have to fundamentally
restructure American society now it's in
arguable that there are always
after-effects of history for everyone at
every time thereafter effects of history
and then the question is whether the
stuff that is happening right now is the
impact of systems that are in place
right now and the left suggestion is
that America is that that the racial and
inequalities that we see right now are a
reflection of a current inequity in
America that must be rectified by
completely remaking the American system
that is the direction we are moving so
bill Hanna Omar of course who puts this
in the in the most bumper sticker
fashion she says the other day that the
virus isn't racist it's the systems we
have in place that are racist the
medical system for example is racist now
what is the
what is the evidence she has that the
medical system of America is racist
she doesn't really present any but the
idea is that on a plane level if more
black people as a percentage that are
dying than white people that means that
the system itself is racist not that the
system was racist 20-30 years ago 40
years ago the segregation was a bad
thing that has impact in terms of wealth
ownership and that may have impacts in
terms of your ability to buy care
because you don't have as much historic
wealth okay that's it that's an argument
but that's not the argument she's making
she's making the argument that today all
of our systems are racist because of
that inequality all inequality is
inequity in today's system so here's am
I making that argument Lee the virus
isn't racist but the systems we have in
place are racist if we do not
holistically address the kind of in
justices that have existed within our
systems then then we will not be able to
fight this this virus in the way that we
need to and we will not be prepared for
other pandemics to come so socialism is
that is the solution to the virus right
complete redistribution slavery
reparations either these are the answers
to the virus which of course is absolute
nonsense because this refuses to even do
the analysis necessary to demonstrate
that higher rates of obesity in the
black community are due to segregation
in 1964 now you actually have to show
the relationship and more than that you
have to show that if you sign everybody
a check that's gonna hop that's gonna
fix everything which of course it is not
going to fix okay it ain't that's not
gonna fix it we've been trying to sign
checks to people who are impoverished in
this country for going on 40 50 years
really since the New Deal but certainly
since the Great Society it has not
alleviated the inequalities among
communities of color signing a check
ain't going to do it
his Bernie Sanders is trying the same
thing Bernie Sanders has a piece in the
near Times today it's called the
foundations of American society are
failing us you wonder when people are
protesting the reason people are
protesting is because they are deeply
suspicious and correctly so that people
like Bernie Sanders are reveling in this
crisis as an opportunity to
fundamentally reshape American society
divide us along racial lines and then
claim that if we want to go back to work
or if that we disagree with his
restructuring of American societies
because we hate black people right that
is it that is the next step in the
media's narrative is that if you want to
go back to work if you think that we
have to ignore
the risks to American society and also
acknowledge that by the way the people
who are losing their jobs are
disproportionately black and Hispanic
and low-income and those people do need
jobs I mean they're going to need to
work now I want them to work they want
to work everybody wants to work but the
idea is that if you acknowledge this
sort of stuff and you don't call instead
for a government top-down reparations
program it levels all of America's
economic wealth is because you're racist
this is this is the direction they're
moving so Bernie Sanders has this piece
in the New York Times he says we are the
richest country in the history of the
world but at the time of massive income
and wealth inequality that's reality
means little to half of our people who
live paycheck to paycheck the 40 million
living in poverty the 87 million who are
uninsured or underinsured a half million
who are homeless in the midst of the
twin crises that we face coronavirus
pandemic and the meltdown of our economy
it is imperative we examine some of the
foundations of American society
understand why they're failing us and
think for a fairer and more just nation
and then he talks about Medicare for all
and then he suggests that we have a
Byzantine network of medical
institutions dominated by profit-making
interests of insurance and drug
companies by the way the hospitals are
all losing money during this and the
hospitals are having to shut down
because they're not doing they're not
doing surgery on demand right but then
Bernie gets to his main point he tries
to tie this to racism
he says it's true that poor and
working-class people are suffering
higher rates of sickness are dying at
much higher rates than wealthy people
which by the way has been true for all
of human history is that poor people are
less healthy generally than wealthy
people and have less access to resources
and wealthy people because they are not
wealthy this is just a reality okay that
it does not mean that the system is
racist but he says it is because the
system is racist he he talks about how
we should while doctors and governors
and mayor's tell us we should isolate
ourselves and stay at home and rich
people head to their second homes in
less populated states working-class
people don't have these options so what
we really need is that he says many in
our country are now beginning to rethink
the basic assumptions underlying the
American value system he says should we
really continue along the path of greed
and unfettered capitalism or should we
go forward in a very new direction he
says we should follow the path of
Franklin Delano Roosevelt who knew that
economic rights must be considered human
rights so we're gonna use the back of
this pandemic in order to completely
reshef tell Americans interact with
their with their government with the
man is supposed to do he says the new
America must fight to end starvation
wages and guarantee a decent paying job
so those who are able to work by the way
you know what just happened
22 million people lost their decent
paying jobs thanks to the government he
says that we have to undertake massive
construction programs that end
homelessness ok they've tried this in
Seattle turns out a lot of people would
prefer to live on the streets some
people are it's very difficult to keep
them in housing because many of them are
drug addicts and schizophrenic
like this is it's a deeper thing we just
build a house and a homeless person has
a house now that's not the way that I
wish it were that easy for were that
easy we'd all be on board he says I get
very tired of the politicians and
pundits who tell us how difficult it is
to bring about fundamental changes in
our society it always seems impossible
until it is done
Nelson Mandela is widely reported to
have said let's get to work and get it
done yet quoting Nelson Mandela
definitely is going to fill in for a
plan you don't have but this is the this
is the next move and this is why people
are protesting right people are saying
we can see you using this for your
political point making for your
political point-scoring
and your times is a piece today titled
how the coronavirus become a new
frontier in the fight for civil rights
collectively the goals are targeted
legislation financial investment
government and corporate accountability
Jesse Jackson is calling for the
creation of a new Kerner commission to
document the racism and discrimination
built into public policies that make the
pandemic measurably worse for some
African Americans so we're going to
divide the country in a time when it
needs to be unified in order to score
political points and then when people
protest to say listen I think that
you're using this for ancillary purposes
and I think that you are using this
crisis for ancillary purposes for many
politicians like Avenue sim to fill in
your state budget with federal dollars
for for politicians like Bernie Sanders
to fundamentally shift the nature of
American free markets for race baiting
politicians to divide us along the lines
of race in suggest that America
continues to be not was continues to be
fundamentally racist at its core the
beta will work view of America and its
history and then Americans say well you
know what I'm kind of suspicious you
guys I'm kind of suspicious how about
this how about were responsible and we'd
like to reopen and then the Huffington
Post labels you a protester from
Charlottesville seriously now that is it
that the the Huffington Post has a piece
today says the president's enable
response of right-wing protesters echoed
his handling of the 2017 violent white
supremacist rally in Charlottesville I
have a question and Trump said you're
allowed to protest I watched her protest
they were all 6 feet apart I mean it was
a very orderly group of people some of
the things that happen are not so
appropriate but in the end it's not
gonna matter because we're starting to
open up our state
okay to equate everybody who's
protesting to go back to work with
people who hate black people is just
insane it since I'm sorry it's nuts
it's but this is the way that the this
is this is the narrative this is the
narrative everyone who's protesting is
bad hearted everyone who wants to reopen
society is is a racist everyone who
doesn't want to remake the American
system on the back of a pandemic is is
denying the realities of a fundamental
American evil you want to divide
everybody and make people you'll
basically ignore government orders and
go back to work this is pretty much how
you do it you want people to pay
attention to the experts they have to be
disinterested disinterested experts have
to be disinterested it can't be Bernie
it can't be caramel Harris
it can't be Oh Hannah Omar it can't be
gavin newsom pushing the progressive
policies on the back of the worst crisis
in modern American history you can't do
that and you can't do that while making
excuses about like how we need 20
million tests a day that's just not
realistic already well we'll be back
here today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we will see you here
tomorrow also tonight I'm on all-access
we'll be hanging out at like 5:00 p.m.
Pacific 8:00 p.m. Eastern so join us
then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
thousands take to the streets around the
country to protest draconian lockdowns
the Liberals and the squishes are
furious but President Trump is cheering
them on and believe it or not the anti
lockdown protesters are getting some
encouragement from of the world's
leading public health experts then
congressman Dan Crenshaw destroys Bill
Maher's anti-trump talking points
Harvard tries to ban homeschooling and
brian Stelter cries all that more check
it out on the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you